hello folks
and welcome to rational science
the only site on the internet that does
physics
right anyways uh last time around we had
a little
sound glitch i have no idea why
or how and all i can do
is uh you know try try and try again
so if you can't hear me for any reason
i'm going to try to keep an
eye on that comment section there
usually i concentrate get so involved in
my stuff that i
concentrate on my lecture and forget to
pay attention
to the folks out there that put comments
anyways i had a rough
week this week my brother
finally died one of them and
he was operated on saturday he lost
half a leg his right leg he was cut just
above the knee
and he was also a paralyzed half of half
his body
and he finally died yesterday and so
yeah he did not survive
he did uh want to die
uh before he went into the operating
room he said goodbye to his wife
and he didn't think he was coming out so
uh he already had that sixth sense that
that he was on his way out and that's
what he would choose to do
anyways he probably didn't want to live
uh
for the rest of his life halfway
paralyzed not being able to speak
um and with half a leg
and yeah we you know one of the things
uh we
take for granted life more than life we
take for granted that the constancy
of life the fact that we see people
around every day and we
expect to see them the next day and
it doesn't occur always or is not always
present that
some people you know do not follow us
all the way and
you know they left get left behind in
the old days um
they used to see death a lot more often
than we do in this
these days especially of kids uh
by the eight early eighteen hundreds at
least fifty percent of the
children this is a calculation they've
done and they figured out
that fifty percent of the children would
die before the age of five
there was a high death rate and we don't
see that anymore
at least not those numbers today you
know almost every kid is allowed to live
the doctors are there they typically
know a little more than the
witch doctors of the past okay and they
have a lot more tools
uh to keep children alive uh whether
that's good or not some people
criticize they say maybe everybody
should not be saved okay that's an
opinion
but the fact is that we do save more
children today
we are more immune to certain diseases
especially childhood diseases
and so you know we live longer ages to
longer ages you know 70 80 whatever 90.
and because of that we don't see death
as
often as we used to okay so
you know when we do see death today it's
like something
out of the ordinary the old days it was
routine
to see people die keep that in mind the
different
uh mental set that we have in those days
okay anyways let me get uh on with the
uh with a first with the ex
extinction part and then i'll move on to
the lecture
and into questions okay uh
yeah thank you guys uh i hope you can
hear me
that's i hope uh my sound doesn't get
cut off
okay here goes a person asks you a
question i'm just gonna
uh run this with the questions that
people made
okay and fellow says must all species
find their
and uh end through an absolute
extinction
okay or do not many species find their
end through changes
and adaptation meaning evolution right
why is a complete extinction the only
possibility for the human species
okay now i didn't determine this or nor
god or mother nature i guess
it's just the way it is right and
separately
what do species deemed living fossils
that have continued millions of years
mean for your theory
theory is of extinction okay the fact
that humans
i say are about to disappear from the
face of the earth
uh we probably don't have i think we
don't have luck
we have less than 100 years for sure
that's
my take on that that's my number i'm
saying we don't have 100 years to go
and uh so this person says you know why
does man have to come to an end
well it just is it's not that there's a
why
like uh you know it's uh written in the
heavens
uh i guess the only way you can see that
or the only focus you can give to that
is that all species are scheduled to die
there is not a single species that lives
forever
okay and you know even uh some people
say well bacteria have lived
quite a long time or some bacteria has
been around for millions of years
i'm not sure the bacteria that were here
maybe
say a billion years ago are the same
bacteria we have here today
i think the bacteria evolved okay
and uh you know there's all kinds of
bacteria out there even today
but i think if the bacteria today saw
the bacteria
of a billion years ago they would run
the other way
they would say i'm not gonna have
anything to do with that
monster okay so i don't think they're
the same bacteria
and let me give you a for instance here
here's a uh the most common
uh they're known as lazarus toxin
uh living fossils or species that
supposedly live forever or have been
rediscovered
to live after there's been a long period
in which they did not or they're not
found in the record okay
and they're the famous lungfish okay
these lungfish you'll see the
african the south american and
australian lungfish
those are around today there you see at
the bottom there bottom right the
devonian lung fish
and that guy is like the neanderthals
compared to these guys i think if these
guys saw that fellow
they would run the other way also you
know they'd be scared of them
because i don't think their genes or the
genetic makeup
is the same i don't think these species
could mate with each other
okay and so you know lungfish is not a
lung fish it's not
a lung fish there are lung fish and
there are lung fish and i'm saying the
lung fish
of millions of years ago have nothing to
do with the lung fish of today
and in fact there is an uh there are a
couple of articles
more than a couple really that talk
about that you'll if you look up
lungfish and look up the articles
uh you'll find that uh they've already
essentially
determined that you know the specialist
that those lungfish
of um you know the devonian you know
you're talking about at least uh 300 400
million years ago
those are not the same lungfish that
you'll see today they've occupied the
same niche
they've um you know they're they they
have
the same general structure they have the
same
function in the oceans but they're not
the same fellows
and you know the same thing will go for
the sharks
you know people say oh the sharks have
been living around like 300 million
years
no it's not the same sharks believe me
after 300 million years
there should have been a uh a
gradual right at least evolution
of those sharks now you might say well
it looks like a shark to me
well yeah if you ask the shark or the
lungfish they'll say that
we're monkeys and they can't see any
difference between a gorilla and a human
you know you all have four legs you got
you're standing up you know and so on
one last tail the other one has one so
you're all monkeys
well that's more or less what we do when
we compare lungfish of
old and lung fish of today so that no
the
no animal lives no species lives forever
and uh some live more than others and
again one of the questions
is you know people say well look the uh
tricera i'm sorry the t-rexes they lived
like two million years
and here we are we've been around what
two hundred thousand three hundred
thousand years maybe that's as far as we
can trace our lineage
today and uh
the issue there is that you know some
species don't last
as long as others in fact in our case
we were able to conquer diseases a lot
more
a lot more faster than some of these
other species out there
so we were able to not only conquer
diseases
and and modify our genetic makeup in a
much faster
time frame and that distinguishes us
from
these other animals which were really a
lot more backward and it took a longer
time for them to do the same thing
and they did it by trial and error and
sifting
of diseases over a lengthy period of
time
millions of years it takes that long a
time
to build a species as big and as
probably as immune to diseases
as a t-rex or a triceratops was
towards the end of the cretaceous okay
and so here let me show you something
else and this is known as convergent
evolution
which again has to do with uh not being
the same species
here you have two species of plants that
have essentially adapted
the same architecture they look
more or less the same and they're two
different types of plants
but they converge upon the same
niche and the same architecture
it's called convergent evolution and one
has nothing to do with the other
okay so they're not parents or you know
related at least not in the short term
maybe
if you take millions of years ago they
probably were but not today
and so you know you gotta think about
that the fact that you get
the animals such as the lungfish today
those are convergent evolutions they're
not the same
evil animal the same lungfish that
existed
in the devonian okay another fellow who
raises another topic he says
patriarchy isn't primitive instead it's
the only thing that works
feminism is just more communism
and doesn't work insufficient birth rate
but i wouldn't expect a
communist to get it patriarchy wasn't
just a stone age it was very
every successful society well what i put
there underneath there the family types
through the ages
again this is a general picture okay and
what you'll find
there is that you have group marriages
existed in the days of the hunter
gathering
societies uh they probably have
matriarchy that's
quite a bit of speculation but it says
that
since everybody had sex with everybody
inside the cave or wherever out there in
in the savage world no one knew who
their father was but
everyone knew who their mother was and
the mother certainly knew their kids but
the fathers didn't know
whether they were the ones okay and so
families apparently
originated or originally you know
came out of this matriarchy society in
the sense that
the kids belonged to the mother okay and
it was also a clan structure
maybe the males had more power or
because they went out probably
for the hunt and the women stayed behind
and they had this division of labor
that's very possible again a lot of this
is just theory uh
speculation you believe in which
everyone you think is right for you
but um at some point we went into this
cindyasmic family
and maybe that also occurred in a way
past also in the uh savagery
age and that's that someone would kidnap
a woman
okay maybe with the help of another a
couple other fellows
and they would all take turns and then
she would become like the bride of that
group
you know so so to speak and uh
so that is said to be also uh
one of the possibilities that happened
in the past and they get this out of
studying
uh societies in the 19th century that's
where they got some of these ideas
at some point we invented patriarchy and
that was where the male
had you know essentially control over
the whole uh extended family
specifically over the slaves and the
wife was
simply the number one slave essentially
she was the head of the slaves from
there we moved on
to the age really starting in
manufacturing where we went into
monogamous and uh the nuclear type of
marriage okay mom and pop and the kids
and yes there was uh some um patriarchy
even to this day in some societies but
patriarchy is really a
um a type of society or type of marriage
that
really existed in the past so now he
this fella is wrong maybe it's not the
stone age but it certainly was the
in the age of farming in the age of
slavery that's where we had patriarchy
you know that type of family died off
over the years we replaced it with the
nuclear or
you could say monogamous monogamous
family even though
it wasn't very monogamous people cheated
okay
and today we have a different type of
world in which we're moving into the
bachelor society
today people don't get married they have
sex casual sex
maybe kids maybe one or two that's about
it and then they separate each one goes
his own way and
then they get new partners and so on
down the line there's no
uh group sex in the in the sense where
you know they all live in the cave or in
in the apartment you could say and live
forever in there
and the men go out and do the hunting
that sort of thing
now that's that's uh old-fashioned
it's out of fashion now it's today we're
headed into a bachelor society in
individualistic society and that also
has to do a lot with the service economy
which does not
encourage in the cities uh to have
large families so the large family is
what's dying
you need the extended family and i think
that's how man will end with this
bachelor
society so yeah patriarchy i think
belongs to the past
doesn't mean that there aren't
patriarchy's out there
obviously there are here and there
you'll find pockets throughout the earth
in different societies especially
backwards societies but the
the life in the city take any city in
the world
and i don't think you'll find much
patriarchy at all
you know very little if anything okay
another fellow
talks about race okay says i think a lot
of us
uh uh kind of have to pick
and choose what we like about these
ideas yeah some of these are radical
ideas i granted but
again the point here is to make you
think not to make you believe
you believe in whatever you want but the
issue is to try to get you to think
and to see things from a different
perspective okay
and so billy's stuck in the neoliberal
age
where we don't know what race is uh-huh
well you know i do address that issue in
my neanderthal book
we have race and we have species the
reason i raise that issue is because
we need to know whether neanderthals
were the same species
as we are and the way i define species
is interbreeding in other words do we
have the ability to produce
viable offspring with a neanderthals
if we separate it too far apart
genetically
okay then we probably would not be able
to have viable children
you know even hybrids any hybrid came
out of there
would probably be sterile okay for
example
and so the question there is
did we separate sufficiently from the
neanderthals
and one issue one factor obviously is
time
assuming we had a common ancestor as as
is
speculated today maybe 500 600 000 years
ago
right that's the first issue and then
the second issue is whether
you know here here you have the
neanderthals he's born
in arctic weather he is born in northern
europe
and this is his hunting ground this is
where he lives
we you know at least though the
assumption i make is
based on the theory that humans came out
of africa
okay so i like that one for now until i
find a better mousetrap again you know
everyone chooses his own assumptions my
assumptions
humans came out of africa humans
are nude neanderthals are nude
but neanderthals are in an environment
cold environment which they can
withstand
humans are the invaders they go into
europe
and no they cannot withstand the cold so
they invent clothes
i think that's why we invented clothes
primarily to be able to withstand the
cold
and so here you have these two animals
assuming they met
which is still yet to be proven okay
assuming they met
one is clothed the other one is looks
like a gorilla
okay essentially you know he's got his
fur okay
and so the question is uh this hairy
animal in this
human which is dressed up i think they
would recognize
each other as different species
immediately
okay by the smell maybe maybe they mark
their territory you know like raise
their legs to say
don't mess around here this is my
hunting ground they probably had
all these signals out there certainly
they couldn't speak the same language
and so i don't think they made it at all
and so
but even if they did the question is
with this
uh lengthy separation in two different
radically different environments could
these two
animals mate and have viable
offspring my answer is no they were
different
species different species
species meaning they cannot uh have
viable offspring
if they interbreed okay and so starting
from that point of view we know what a
species is now what is race well race
within
you know race is really a cosmetic issue
it's more a political issue than a
scientific issue in that sense
you can ask the scientific question why
is there a man that's black another one
that's white another one that's yellow
another one that's brown you can ask all
that
and and search for an answer to that
question to that kind of question
that would be a scientific issue but
other than that it's more a political
issue because that's what this guy is
insinuating you say well you know i
don't like blacks or i don't like yellow
so i don't like whites maybe he's black
you know so it's like
you know that's his point of view and
that doesn't enter the picture
in science uh those are cosmetic
differences you know and we are
territorialists
and so here you have the white man and
he conquers uh for example in the united
states you have the white man come over
and he kicked the indian out the
american indian
and they could each recognize each other
not only by their outward appearance but
their culture
you know many things involved there so
you get language you know so they could
recognize each other as different
and different means enemy you know we
stick together here and they stick
together over there we have to fight
them
and whoever wins well that guy wins
sorry you know that's
that's life and uh then
you know they the white man brought the
black man you know dragged him over to
to the americas and and now
there's also hey that's the enemy and
where the whites are they're the blacks
you know and so on
and that's all political you know so
those are issues that don't
enter the picture in science the only
part again is
why did some uh
humans end up being black others white
others yellow and other brown or
whatever god maybe some green ones out
there
and so the that's a scientific question
now um as far as uh
you know the genetics
people we will be surprised but we're
not
there are no races as far as genetics
are concerned
we are all essentially the same you take
a black man
from africa you take a yellow man
somewhere in asia
you take a white man from europe or
russia or the united states
and you you bring them together and they
have the same genetic code
essentially they are brothers and
sisters
and you know we can mate with that
person because
you say well he's a different race yeah
but you can mate and have viable
offspring
and so we're the same species we have
these cosmetic
differences pigmentation whatever and
uh you know that doesn't prevent us from
mating having
viable offspring so we're the same race
same species race is more cosmetic
in that sense there are no genetic
differences
between the so-called races okay that's
the point you gotta
emphasize when when you talk about race
okay
okay next issue here uh
fellow says says if you think that
farmers will be able to defend their
crops uh
take a look at the south african farmer
attack farm attacks
obviously the attacks aren't motivated
by food but by racial hatred
but the point remains that would be our
future
yeah this fellow says that you know you
had this
the blacks rise up once they got a
little more power and they were
a little jealous or they wanted revenge
against the white settlers who had
conquered them a hundred years earlier
and here were their offspring
they were the owners and still are the
owners as far as i know uh of many of
the farms in south africa and that whole
region
in southern africa and so you know a lot
of the blacks say well you know we we
want some of that land back because
that belonged to the i don't know the
zulus or whatever and uh so
what are you gonna do i mean it's like
the uh
israelites today they want their land
back they say it was stolen from them uh
since biblical times and so now they
have the power in their
um uh what is it uh
overcoming the um the palestinian
uh people you know and so there's this
war
uh because of ideals because these
people say that land was ours
and now we're taking it back now that we
have the power you know that sort of
thing
and that happens and has happened
throughout the world in different places
uh on and off constantly you know it's
like like if the incas today of peru
wanted their land back from the white
settlers the white spaniards who took it
from them
you know and they go and say hey white
man from lima
we want our land back so you know
because you stole it from
for our great grandfathers you know
you know politics again uh but uh
this was the issue the issues that
another guy answered says make no
mistake even the amish owned guns
this isn't south africa and again all i
can say is the amish owned guns to hunt
rabbits okay not to hunt people
amish don't kill people under any
circumstances
it's against their religion so to say
that
these people are gonna if you kill one
of theirs uh one of their own you know
in the uh
amish camp they're not only gonna pull
their guns out and say and you know
create a posse and come after you no way
okay in fact it's happened where there
was a crazy guy went into
one of these schools and killed several
girls in the amish town
and what the amish did was pray for him
and that that was their answer okay they
prayed for his soul
so you know you got to think about all
these things uh the amish
don't go killing people it's against
their religions against their way of
thinking
they wouldn't do that under any
circumstances because again
they have this invisible thing that
holds them back and it's their beliefs
okay they're
they're not violent people neither are
the mennonites by the way okay
okay um another issue
fella says speaking of amputees
referring to my brother
okay why does god hate them okay i like
that
the bible and other religious traditions
uh
often refer to medic medical miracles
performed by jesus
or other figures yeah okay the blankens
see
the crippling walk and usually it's the
other way around they say that the death
can see
and the blanket here you know that's
more or less the miracles they used
that jesus used to perform and seemingly
fatal
disease uh can be cured okay
you see it in nature a starfish or a
salamander can
lose a limb and have it regenerate
okay but god wasn't uh won't perform
this miracle
for human amputees and it seems to me it
could only be because he hates them
hates the amputees or man i don't know
which one he's referring to
but uh fellow's got a problem in
reasoning i mean first of all you know
lions
don't grow their legs when they when one
is chopped off
i need to do hyenas i don't think that
eagles grow their wing if you cut one of
them off
there's so many animals that do not grow
their limbs back if you cut
that limb off uh hopefully god doesn't
hate all of his creation okay that's the
first one i want to mention okay
but uh here's a a little education for
him i'm gonna define the word
christian what is a christian okay let's
find out what a christian is
okay this is a scientific definition of
christian okay you heard it here first
here it goes
okay christian it's a person who never
read the bible
okay so here's poor old god and he's um
typing his manuscript it's gonna become
the bible
and it's a bestseller but nobody reads
it
so it's the best seller and the worst
reader you could say okay
nobody reads the bible and if they don't
read the bible you can say well he's a
christian
that's why he's a christian still okay
and um
but let's read it for a second let's
let's look at some passages where god
really tells us what he thinks of us
from the bible okay this is strictly
from the bible
god says and there was not a man to till
the ground he had made all these animals
everything
he didn't make by any chances he didn't
make uh
anyone the to work in the garden so in
the lord god formed man out of the dust
of the ground and breathed into his
nostrils the breath of life and man
became a living soul
uh i think you know we'd like to know
what the process is
how god turned clay or
whatever from the ground into carbon
because
you know we don't have our bodies are
not made of silicon our bodies are made
of
carbon so how we turn silicon to the
carbon is
is the miracle we'd like to know okay he
says he just did it by
breathing on him that's quite a magic
trick
anyways and the lord god planted a
garden eastward in eden and there he put
man whom he formed okay so now he's got
a gardener
and so he says so god created man in his
own
image in the image of god created he him
okay so obviously man looks like god god
looks like us in general terms right
maybe with a beard maybe without a beard
but essentially he looks like us
and then he continues male and female
created he them
so i don't know if god is a female
doesn't look like it looks like god
is macho okay and that's not surprising
because um
because you know uh we dominated women
uh in fact if you look at history we've
um
that was essentially the first uh
class distinction between men and women
then we went
between men and men but originally i
think it was between men and women
if you read engels book the origin of
the family
private property in the state uh you'll
read it there quite well
anyways uh what uh engle said is that
yeah first there was a division
between women and men and where men
started dominating women
primarily i think because of war
men were more qualified to do war and
women stayed behind and became widows
okay and from there you know men thought
they had the right
to rule over women and that's what's
happened for most of our
civil civilized history what happened
before that
is more theory and speculation but i
think we can safely say that once we
started civilization
meaning war you know
conquest stealing that's called
civilized
uh that's when we conquered women and
then we conquered slaves and so on down
the line
okay but yeah um we had this division
and you know when moon were left behind
but uh the issue here is that um
uh this uh history that we've had
uh where we relegated women you know um
is something we we uh i think we could
not have avoided as i showed before
there was a transition from uh a
patriarchal society
or uh clan or whatever you want to call
it
to a uh to a society where we had this
monogamous supposedly at least in
in nominally okay monogamous uh
marriage or you can call it nuclear
family
and today we have the bachelor and now
that we have the bachelor we have the
women more or less
come up to par again after millio
thousands of years
and part of that is because they work in
the same type of
work they do the same type of work that
we do that men do
and so there should be no reason for the
distinction
uh in the family in the in the
uh matrimony that we can call it that
because again a lot of people don't even
get married today
so yeah we have this evolution and
i don't think we can turn the clock back
on that
okay
races again uh not important
uh scientifically other than why we have
different pigment colors that one
might be a topic to
investigate okay so let me finish with
this uh anyway one more thing just god
you know again
uh if god created us he created us
in his own image i think we're his
favorite creature
so under no circumstances is it because
god hates us or
amputees uh again most
animals especially most mammals cannot
grow their limbs back again so that's
faulty reasoning okay i always put this
up here
uh that you've got to do 101 extension
101 before
trying to do 102 which means you first
you have to address
mass extinction you got to do a little
research on that to make sure you're
solid on mass extinction you understand
how mass extinctions
really occurred and when you read out
there a lot of the papers and i'm
talking about scientific papers and
papers that are being published
you'll get a feel that these people have
no clue whatsoever
they have no idea how mass or background
extinctions ever happened
okay and so yeah all i can say is
that's the case uh we we don't have a
theory
uh i do have a theory i think that you
can sink your teeth into
and by that i mean that at least it
makes sense i'm saying that if you
remove food
we will die no matter what and so the
only issue is whether
you can understand not not believe but
understand
that if we remove food from the planet
humans die and the way we remove food
from the planet is by killing money
if money is no more food is no more
because no one has an incentive to
produce it or distribute it
very simple theory and right now i have
a lot of people who have
no understanding of understanding not
belief but
understanding that without money we
don't produce food
and that's where i'm stuck right now
with so many people they
they just can't wrap their brains around
that idea that without money there is no
food
you know the whole chain of uh
of pushing money in one direction and
eventually
getting that to produce food they don't
understand that
they don't understand that if we kept
that those chains
uh that whole system disintegrates
completely
and then yeah once you get that then uh
if food is the cause that the trigger
that caused the mass extinctions
in the past if you extrapolate it to man
you can
conclude that without money we have no
food and without food
we certainly will die it's not a it's
not an
if it's a question of when right
okay let's move on to the subject matter
of today
see if i can get this up here give me a
second here
okay and what we have is um
i've been reviewing geometry last couple
weeks
and the issue here is that you know we
have no figures
in geometry there are no true genuine
figures in geometry why is that
important for the subject of today
because i'm going to be talking about
black holes
and the question is whether the black
hole is a geometric figure
you might say well bill where'd you get
that i mean wasn't it a star that
collapsed on its
on on itself on its by gravity and
gravitational collapse
yeah but what do you end up with you end
up with
a point in the center
of what is known as an event horizon
which
is uh you know like this volume or this
region that surrounds that center
that point in the center and so we need
to know what a point is because
that's what a black hole is it's a point
and you say okay what is a point well we
already covered that uh point
is a location it's not a geometric
figure okay it's a location and for
hundreds of years now you know we've
been fooled into thinking that we were
looking
at a geometric figure that is always
represented with a dot it could be a
typically it's a two-dimensional dot
just uh
you hit the pen against the paper and
you're looking at it as a
two-dimensional
thing there right and some people say
well it's got some relief yeah
so you can say it's three dimensional
but the point here is that
when you have a little dot on a piece of
paper or a chalk mark on the board we
think of that as a two-dimensional
figure think of it as a circle okay
but they but a circle is two-dimensional
and so the question is you know is a dot
two-dimensional well a dot is a
two-dimensional figure but that's not
what a point is the point
is this dot this two-dimensional circle
that represents what a location
so the the point is really a location
and that's what the geometer is going to
work with he's not going to work with a
dot
he's not going to work with a circle
he's going to use those as pictorial
representations
of this abstraction known as location
okay and i mathematically call it
position
because they designate it for example
with
a an ordered pair the most common one
you know cartesian coordinates
uh could be a triplet you know etc
so what is the point we're talking about
a location of
a location on something so if you have a
wall if you have a ball if you have a
cube whatever you have out there
the dot represents a location pictorial
representation of a location on this
cube
on this circle on this wall and whatever
you put there
okay so that's how it works and so it
represents a location
but then the question is if it's a
location why didn't the greeks
who invented all this stuff for us or
served in a gold platter
to to us why didn't they just call it a
location
i mean if what they're going to be using
is a location call it a location
why call it a point and mislead you to
believe
that they're referring to a geometric
figure such as a two dimensional circle
you know a plane and call that thing
a zero dimensional point when they
really mean
non-dimensional location okay
we see how this gets confusing because
then they'll tell you
we cannot define the point well of
course you can't define the point
because you're using the dot
of physics which is an object it's a
figure
it's a it's a two-dimensional figure on
the one hand
but then you're trying to define it as a
zero-dimensional
what what is a zero dimensional whatever
you're talking about a concept and
what's the concept location
okay so we get to the to the issue where
um we get here where the
where we're going to build the line the
next geometric figure
we call it a one-dimensional line and it
looks more or less like this
it's just a string of locations
and what they're talking about is a an
itinerary
okay that's what it is so you say well
you know
if these are the foundations of
mathematics
okay the question is how rotten is
geometry
it's i mean it looks like you built your
uh
building on quicksand
okay because look at the foundations the
foundation is
the dot which is a location it's
represented by that ball or
two-dimensional plane uh circle whatever
and then they put a another
two-dimensional figure which is an
elongated rectangle very elongated a
rectangle
it's obviously two-dimensional both of
them are because you can see both of
them you can't see anything below
two dimensions and what is it they're
talking about locations what is a
1d line made out of one dimensional line
made of
zero dimensional locations what are they
talking about they're talking about one
dimensional something no they're talking
about
a series of locations they're talking
about an itinerary a trajectory
maybe an orbit if it's curved okay so
that's what they're talking about that's
what a line
is that's how it's defined but then they
put a little stick and they say
see that's the line no that's not the
line because they have no use in
mathematics in geometry they have no use
whatsoever
for that stick or for that little ball
there have they have no use whatsoever
they're going to be doing math they're
going to be doing angles they're going
to be
talking about parallel and perpendicular
so they have no use for these geometric
the the figure itself
okay they have no use for figures in
mathematics
and that's what geometry is today it's
just a bunch of relations
that tries to unite mathematics
with physics in fact it's the origin
geometry is the origin
of so-called mathematical physics
mathematical physics
is a contradiction in terms it's an
oxymoron
because you have math which is a
language
it's a language that can only describe
and you have physics physics deals with
objects and the purpose of physics is to
explain
to explain what mechanisms never
the twain shall meet you cannot merge
physics with math
math with physics and this is the
problem here
because geometry tries to merge math
with physics
and you say well okay we need to
establish relations we want to do
measurements we want to
come up with calculations and equations
yeah fine leave that all within math
don't bring it into physics
in physics we have to explain how mother
nature does her
stuff out there we need to know how she
does gravity how she does light how she
does
atomic behavior you know quantum jumping
and that kind of thing
or magnetism and electricity that's what
physics is about that's what we want
that's what the ordinary person out
there wants to understand he doesn't
want to do math
he doesn't care about math that's why
physics has become so unpopular
among people nobody cares about it
because all these people come in there
with math and with
abstract concepts new concepts they
invent every day with words
this long you know and people say i
don't want to deal with all that you
guys do
you you're the experts you deal with all
that just give us the bottom line
and the bottom line are the physical
interpretations
and what are these people saying they're
saying nonsense they're saying a
particle would be at two places at once
they're saying there's a physical object
called space time out there they're
saying there was a big bang an origin to
matter
even though they're atheists and they
don't believe that there's a god that
created the universe they do
believe that there was a moment of
creation that matter came out of what
out of
nothing or energy or whatever they want
to call it
so so they have all these ridiculous
irrational explanations
on the one hand which they serve to the
public and the public believes them
simply on the basis of authority because
nobody wants to deal with the math
and so yeah man of physics has become a
very unpopular
thing nobody does physics out there
nobody cares about it
it's just a specialist who deal with
physics and they're all brainwashed in
the same way at the universities
otherwise they don't get the degrees
they don't get an advisor
and what do they talk about well they
talk about the nonsense nonsense such as
what
a black hole okay that's the kind of
nonsense they talk about black holes
and yeah people say whoa we took a
picture of them well i'll get to that in
a second
anyways here's the famous circle
okay and again that's an orbit i talked
about that in the past
okay here's the cube okay and what is a
cube is a cube
a uh a solid figure no it's a hollow
it's made out of all these points okay
so the question is whether that is a
3d object or it's a bunch of locations
are we talking about a perimeter is that
what we're talking about
in which not even the ones in the center
are there because it's like um
they look at lines and so uh it's like
they have a cube made of lines that go
from
corner to corner and it's essentially
uh a cube
is a six sided window or six
windows on each covering it
and it's got no window pane there's no
glass in it
okay so it's just the lines and in this
case this is another version it's just a
bunch of points
so the question is is that what a cube
is because this is a hollow not a cube
okay and not a solid okay so
what is the problem with all this the
problem is that again they're going to
extrapolate
all these notions that they have in
geometry they're going to extrapolate
them
into general relativity general
relativity what is it
it's a geometric theory
of gravity geometric theory of gravity
i didn't say that these people say it
i'm just repeating it i'm just
regurgitating what they already said
it's a geometric theory of gravity
they're going to explain
gravity as a g as
being a geometry of space time the
warping of space time the bending of
space time
what are they bending they're bending
time they're warping
time not uh facetiously
or or even figuratively they're saying
literally they're warping time
okay so why doesn't the earth fly out of
the solar system
because there's a warp wall of time that
comes in contact with the skin
of the planet okay that's what's
happening here
and because they have to explain why the
earth doesn't fly out of the solar
system
and you say what prevents the earth from
flying out if it's
swinging around the sun and so
you know we we say that every atom of
the earth is tied to every atom of the
sun we have a physical
entity holding the earth now we see why
the earth doesn't fly out of the sun
we have a mechanism that is valid what
is their mechanism their mechanism
is not that the earth is connected
physically to the sun
their mechanism is that there's a
roulette kind of thing and
our earth is a little ball that rolls
around this roulette
so the skin of the earth is coming in
contact with space-time with warped
time and so they're saying that warp
time is what prevents physically
prevents the earth from flying out of
the solar system
that's their explanation that's a
physical interpretation
and of course when you throw this in
their face they say well you're not
supposed to take the analogy literally
that's their answer you're not supposed
to take the analogy
literally you got to take math they say
to understand what we're saying
we want to know the physical
interpretation we don't care about your
stupid math
that's the answer to you we want to know
the physical interpretation what
prevents
a solid object such as the earth not
solid completely but i mean
it's quite solid right it's a rock this
rock this roundish rock rolls around the
sun what prevents this rock that we know
is here because we
put our feet on it you know what
prevents it from flying out of the solar
system what comes
what prevents it from flying out and
these people are saying warp time and
then they
when you put them against the wall and
say well what do you mean what time it's
a concept
they say well you're not supposed to
take the analogy literally you got to
take math to understand
that's the answer so yeah we have
irrational explanations and what people
want to know
if if we can bring them back into
physics is the mechanism
that's what people want to understand
they don't want your equations okay
okay so what happens it turns out that
a black hole you know is a um
what is it people are not aware that
it's a zero dimensional
entity yeah it's a zero dimensional
thing
and you say uh what do you mean a zero
dimensional thing
let me show you here these are
comments that people make
i know let me first start with this i
want to cover this
first um so what does a mathematician do
if he wants to give you a physical
interpretation like
i just said like you know why doesn't
the earth fly out of the solar system
well i'll give you an analogy i like
this analogy that's why i don't want to
skip over it
uh you see a hole in the wall okay you
see this okay
this is what you see on the wall and you
call the expert of math and you say
okay tell me how that hole was made
can you can you explain that and the guy
comes in there with his ruler
you know whatever he brings in his
calculator
and he measures and he does all his
experiments that he needs to do
and he calculates he comes up with an
equation
and he said yeah i can tell you exactly
how that hole was made
okay and this is what he proposes he
proposes that it was made by
a unicorn that's what he tells you
say a unicorn but hold it unicorns don't
exist what do you mean a unicorn
and uh and the guy says well yeah you're
not supposed to take the analogy
literally what do you mean i mean
you're giving me an explanation how the
hole was made you're saying it's a
unicorn i'm telling you that unicorns
don't exist
and your answer is well uh you're not
supposed to take it
the analogy literally that's the kind of
answer you get from these people
and so here here's a black hole okay
uh because they they talk about them in
these conferences they
talk about their equations all that
fancy stuff
and they even took a picture of it and
here's a picture of it
isn't that fascinating look at that look
at that picture
beautiful picture so what the hell are
we staring at
are we staring at a black hole as they
say
actually not what you're staring at is
according to them okay
matter falling into a black hole
remember a black hole is zero
dimensional
and a lot of people have trouble with
that in fact i
uh when i had my uh talk with garippy
fellow in canada who has a show
i told him that that's what a black hole
is a black hole is zero dimensional
and he said well no that's not true
and so i showed him evidence and he
still did not believe me
you know i didn't create the evidence i
was just putting out what the experts
out there say
and he still refused to believe that a
black hole is zero dimension
because if you can show to anyone
that a black hole is zero dimensional
and they actually come to grips with
that thought
with a notion that a black hole is zero
dimensional it's just a location with
nothing in it
it's just infinite density uh because
it's got all this mass and zero volume
so you got infinite density
and so what is a black hole well if it's
zero dimensional it's not much of
anything
that's what it it's a point it's a
geometric point which is what a location
and this location is surrounded by what
an event horizon
which is the best way i i like to
explain uh event horizon is that you
know campfire
you put a campfire and the heat you know
has a certain distance
after a while if you move far enough you
won't feel it you'll be cold
you'll be out in the cold still right
it's like the heat doesn't reach you
but the closer you get to the campfire
well you know there's this radius
in which there's still heat and that's
more or less what a black hole is the
region of influence
of a black hole at the velocity of light
in which it overcomes the
escape velocity as it's called that
reaches up to the event horizon after
that you know you're
you're pretty much scot-free you know
and so
it's a it's a zero-dimensional location
infinite density that's surrounded by a
region of
influence of which the perimeter is
called
the event horizon that's more or less
what a black hole is
so far we have nothing in front of us
it's just abstractions
mathematical abstractions that's all we
have we don't have a physical object
for example we don't know why or how
a a black hole would be able to
influence
a star that is a few light years away
how would it move it around itself
by what physical means that's the
question
and you cannot use the word mass and say
well it does it through mass
or gravity those are concepts we need to
know what physical entity is in contact
physical contact with that star
and that's where we we lack an
understanding because these people are
not putting a physical object between
the black hole which is already not a
physical object
and the star we need to know what's
connecting them
physically is there a connection or not
and what they say is you know the black
hole war space time and again we get to
this
issue where they're warping time and
that's what's compelling the star to
move around
like a little ball around the roulette
that's that's the answer
so the first thing i want to establish
is that a black hole is
zero dimensional for those of you who
have a little
mental capacity to understand a black
hole is zero dimensional is that what i
say
no i'm going to put evidence from the
you know gurus from the head honchos of
general rotaty
okay if you don't believe them i don't
know who you're going to believe that
you don't have to believe me i'm just
going to put their testimony so that
you understand what these people are
telling you hopefully you're opening
your eyes your ears and listen to what
these people are saying okay here is the
first one
first testimony uh we called to the
witness stand mr stephen hawking okay i
hope you understand who he is
or remember who he is he died a couple
years ago he wrote a book called the
brief history of time
uh what is it uh i think it's 87 or 78
as
87 okay 1987. and he says the following
and this has to do with chandrasekhar
who won the nobel prize
for demonstrating that a black hole
is zero dimensional he proved it
mathematically
okay let me repeat that because some
people haven't heard that yet
he chandrasekhar proved
that a black hole is zero dimensional he
proved it mathematically
okay we got that and here's
i'm just repeating what this man's gonna
say now he says chandrasekhar calculated
that a cold star
of more than about one and a half times
the mass of the sun
would not be able to support itself
against its own gravity
one and a half times the sun collapses
too
you know it can't support itself against
its own gravity what does it mean
would it collapse to infinite density
what is infinite density means no volume
that's what infinite density means no
volume you can put
as much mass you got it doesn't matter
because if you have
no volume you've got infinite density
you're dividing by zero
okay that's essentially what it is
eddington was shocked by the
that implication and he refused to
believe
chandrasekhar's result uh arthur
eddington was
chandrasekhar's supervisor his boss
and he said i'm not gonna let you
publish that nonsense you're not going
to ridicule the mathematical
establishment
so he was dedicated against that and not
only him as we
will see also einstein who was a big man
by the time right
eddington thought it was simply not
possible that a star could collapse
to what to a point
what was a point in geometry a zero
dimension non-dimensional
location that's what a point is okay
einstein himself wrote a paper in which
he claimed that stars would not
shrink to zero size
what did einstein say that it it was not
possible for a star to shrink
to zero size no radius no diameter no
circumference
i hope i hope that's clear i mean people
then say no
they never said that here you have it
everybody's talking about zero size
uh infinite density etc
however he was awarded the nobel prize
chandra sucker
uh in 1983 for his early work on the
limiting mass of cold stars
chandrasekhar had shown that the
exclusion principle could not
halt the collapse of a star more massive
than the chandrasekhar
limit he proved mathematically through
an equation
that a black hole is zero dimensional
it a star that is bigger than the sun so
many times bigger it doesn't matter
collapses to zero size i think it's
clear
okay but uh some people say well that's
plural
hawking he's not around anymore he's got
no authority okay let's bring some more
proof evidence okay people need
authority to believe
so let's make them believe this is a
black hole as you can see it's zero
dimensional what does a black hole look
like
like that it looks like zero dimensional
nothing okay
okay so um here's another testimony
this fall's name is chodri and he's uh
he wrote a book and uh published it and
we're in
canberra at the cambridge university
press okay so
he was a teacher a professor for many
years in different universities okay so
he's not a nobody he's a somebody okay
not the biggest somebody but certainly a
guy who is specialist
in in this kind of subject matter in
black holes
says on solving the equation with a
particular value rho
of central density you will get a model
of a star with mass
m and radius r okay plot
r radius as a function of m mass
right and show that r falls to
zero falls to zero when m
is equal to the chandrasekhar mass if
you can do
all these then you can you have repeated
the calculation for which
chandrasekhar won the nobel prize
i hope you understood all of that if you
have
two fingers worth of uh brain okay
i'm sure you can understand that they're
talking about zero size
okay you still don't believe we'll bring
uh mr harrison to the
witness stand and we'll have him testify
he's a professor
at toronto university many years he's in
the prominent on the internet
and you can visit his site name is david
harrison
and says if the mass of a star is
greater than about three solar masses
here we're talking about three solar the
other guys are one and a half okay fine
it goes through the neutron star stage
and keeps collapsing in this case the
gravitational attraction is so intense
the neutrons are literally what crushed
out of existence crushed out of
existence they turn into empty space
into nothing that's what he meant we
call the object
a black hole i hope everybody understood
straightforward i characterize a black
hole as an object whose gravitational
pressure is so intense
that the matter of the object again is
crushed
out of existence and then he goes on to
make a calculation for the earth and say
well this is
if we could crush the earth to such and
such size then we would get a black hole
and again he says you know uh the issue
is that if
uh if it's got enough mass it can
continue to collapse until there is no
matter in there there is no
structure there is no no no nothing
there is no matter and the issue there
is again that
people in high school get educated to
repeat
verbatim you know that masses the
quantity of matter or a measure of the
quantity of matter
it turns out that black hole has no
matter whatsoever
and yet it has mass it's got infinite
mass
almost you know it's got all the mass
you want to put in there whatever the
star had at the beginning
whatever it collected so it's got more
than zero mass
but it's got zero matter and so if mass
is a measure of the quantity of matter
a black hole should have zero mass
and yet here they talk about all this
mass that moves stars around that sucks
their
skin their gaseous skin into the black
hole which is the picture that you saw a
minute ago
and they say all this happens because of
mass
but a black hole has no matter because
all of it has been
crushed out of existence you figure it
out see it makes any sense to you
okay are we gonna stop there now we have
a little more informal but still
popular uh version here this is from
space.com and that one comes
usually from writers who
essentially translate some of the
papers that the mathematicians write
that
are unintelligible for the public and so
these guys kind of translated and bring
it down to the level of the
human mind the normal human mind okay
and
so here's what uh what the space.com
uh said this is in 2004 as to what lies
in the region between a singularity what
is a singularity
a uh location in the center of
an event horizon which is a spherical
region that
covers the center that's in
that's in this volume okay um between
singularity and and its event horizon
physicists have always drawn a blank
yeah more less a blank like what is
there that's a blank two okay
there's nothing there physicists have
always drawn a blank
literally yeah no matter what type of
material
form the singularity originally right
the area inside the event horizon or the
volume right
was supposed to be devoid of any
structure or measurable characteristics
there is nothing inside a black hole in
black hole is zero dimensional no matter
whatsoever
there is nothing there so far according
to physics
okay i don't care what the
mathematicians say
there's nothing inside a black hole and
a black hole is
made of nothing literally
blank just like this guy said
okay um so here's the million dollar
question for you
to ponder hey uh millionaire question
it's uh it's a black hole zero d
uh if if it is then
does it qualify as a figure
because if it's zero dimensional it
crushed all matter out of existence
there's no body there
there's no shape then what the hell
do we have in front of us is it a
geometric figure can we replace
uh that nothingness with a point and say
with a dot right
and call it a point it's a point what is
a point well the point is the dot or is
it the location
if it's just the location so far we have
nothing in there you got to tell me
what's in the location
and what they're saying is what you have
in the location is a location
that's what you have and they can
pinpoint it with
the coordinates right whatever they as
they call them
number lines and what's in there in that
location
absolutely nothing all it has is runaway
mass
what does that mean well i don't care
because i need to have a physical object
to show how that
center of nothing influences a
star that is gazillions of miles away
that's what we need to figure out we
need to figure out the mechanism
we don't care about their math we don't
care about their mass what we want is a
mechanism for that you need objects and
so far we have no object in front of us
because they tell you in your face
that matter has been crushed out of
existence
what the hell are we talking about as
far as a black hole
about this so-called uh entity this
so-called geometric figure represented
by a point
we have nothing in front of us and when
they say well you know
you're not supposed to take the analogy
literally well i haven't understood your
mechanism sorry
you know and it doesn't mean that i have
to take a course in math
algebra calculus or whatever to
understand what you're saying you
you know you should be able to tell me
like einstein said
if you can't explain it to you know
barmaid then you don't
know it well enough okay okay and so
what's uh one of the big
the biggest problem and here you see it
uh two
concepts do not make an object it's the
other way around
two objects make a concept
concept is a relation between at least
two objects
that's what a concept is that's the
definition of the word concept
a relation between two concepts or a
word that invokes
at least two objects you need two
objects to come up with any
concept because the concept is a
relation but you cannot put
two concepts and make an object
i cannot take intelligence and love put
them together and come up with a rock
and that's the big problem here here you
have a
location which is the center of whatever
it's the center of the event horizon and
what is the event horizon
it's the perimeter of the center
so it's like a circular definition we
have a point in the center
which is a location and it's surrounded
by a concept called the event horizon
which is what a
region of influence so we have two
concepts and so far we have no object
and again two concepts do not an object
make
conclusions there we go
this is what you can take home with you
to the bank okay
you can put your hand in the fire for
this uh
geometry was con misconceived from the
start
point line uh plain all that stuff
misconceived that's why they can't
define it even to this day they just
tell you
we cannot define these terms they're
undefinable terms or primitive terms or
whatever they say you know
they cannot define these terms because
you don't define objects
in physics in science you point to them
they should be able to point to a point
point to a line
point to a circle or any plane and not
have to define it
now plane is a category but certainly
line
and point are not line and point are two
dimensional figures one is a 2d
circle maybe a dot right and the other
one is an extended
rectangle which is the so-called stick
called
a line that's what we have objectively
in front of us
okay anything more than that is in your
tiny mind not in mine
okay uh all i see in front of me is a
stick and the other one is a
little dot a circle that's what we have
objectively in front of us
i don't have to read more into it than
what's in front of me
if i have to read more into it than
what's in front of me
then we're not talking about a geometric
figure now we're talking about a concept
now you're asking me to make believe
you're asking me to be a mime and do
juggling with
with uh balls that don't exist that's
what you're asking me to do
all figures of the irrational discipline
known as geometry
why is it irrational because it's
founded on has
rotten foundations are locations
and itineraries there is not a single
figure in all of geometry today
that is not a bunch of locations meaning
itineraries
they are not sticks and stones they are
itineraries and locations okay
and geometry is first is the first
attempt to merge
math and physics into a religion known
as mathematical physics
that's why you have irrational
explanations today
because they started with rotten
foundations they carried them over
into mathematical physics and today we
have this so-called
religion irrational discipline
called mathematical physics which
attempts to merge math with physics when
one has nothing to do with the other you
can do math over here i mean i did a lot
of math in my life
but it's got nothing to do with a
physical aspect which is
uh what people want to know out there
which is
mechanisms they want to know how mother
nature does gravity how mother nature
does light how mother nature does
electricity that's what people want to
know
and then they're done with physics they
don't want to have anything more to do
physics once they understand
why they get a shock when they put their
fingers you know in a
socket mathematical physics is casually
equated with science that's the problem
today
mathematical physics is not science
under any circumstance
we need rational explanations to to do
science
uh irrational explanations uh we had a
lot of them with traditional religions
all we have now with math fizz is just a
new type of
religion that's all it is and the
priests are known as mathematicians
we call mathematicians and the black
hole of mathematical physics
is consistent with the irrational
evolution of geometry
remember mathematical physics really
starts around the time of newton maybe a
little earlier maybe 100 years earlier
or so
that's when it really takes strength you
know and gets
all this energy behind it until then you
know it was just more
everybody would study geometry and then
you know do measurements calculations
all based on geometry
then when you get into newton's days now
you get more sophisticated algebra
and geometry and i'm sorry in calculus
and so on
and now this thing takes off and people
think that they're going to figure out
the invisible entities that mother
nature
uses out there to do her her stuff
they associate it with mathematical
physics they say oh we're going to
figure this out through math
through equations true measurement and
turns out these are invisible intangible
entities you're not going to figure them
out with any equation
an equation has no power to give you
any information about the nature of the
physical
entity that underlies all these
mechanisms okay
and then uh like all other figures it is
not a figure okay
uh they they have no figures in geometry
and so
black hole is not a figure a black hole
is a location
that moves stars around and sucks their
gases and we have no
idea how a black hole does it
okay okay let me get to the
questions we had um
people ask uh questions mainly regarding
objects things some with regard to
existence but
people are concerned about the word
object what do i say i'll put this up
front
uh the definition the scientific
definition of the word object destroys
all religions okay that's that's the
bottom line okay
and you'll see why okay here's the first
question regarding object the fellow
says
i have never seen or had any kind of
contact with your wife
uh yeah okay thank you for telling me
at least i can eliminate one person from
the 8 billion people on the planet okay
does that mean she doesn't have a 3d
body moving around
referring to the word object body thing
okay
figure and here's the answer okay we can
get this answer up here
what's the problem with what this
gentleman is saying well uh here it is
now it means that your definition of the
word object
has bombed out you've got an irrational
definition because
you think that an object is that which
you can see or touch
and you don't have to see her you don't
have to touch her she's an object before
you see a toucher okay and each and
every human
qualifies as an object because any human
has shape and not because you have seen
or touched every single human
is the chinese on the other side of the
planet not an object because you can't
see or touch him
he disappears as an object do you have
to see or touch him
in order to uh for for that
uh chinese man to become a an object
or the tree or the table that he has
do you have to see and touch it until
then a table is not an object
no hopefully the only
property all objects have is shape
that is a universal property of objects
the only
universal property of all objects right
and uh so here are the list of words
that you cannot use to define the word
object remember
we have eight billion people in this
conference room
eight billion people on the planet that
are in this conference room the doors
are locked
we can't leave the conference room we
can't stop
start doing physics until we define the
word object
why because the golden principle of
physics is you can't do physics without
an object but would there be a move
what are you staring at what what would
you do experiments with assuming
experiments were part of science
you know what are you staring at what
are you watching what what phenomenon is
happening without
objects so you need things you need
objects you need bodies to do
physics and the question is uh
do we have to define the word object
then we need to know what an object is
for the purposes of physics
and that's why the definite the
definition of the word
object destroys all religions because
now you have to tell me whether
your god is an object or a concept
which one is he or it or whatever
which one is god an object or concept
okay so here are the words that you
cannot use to define
or that fail so if you have any of these
criteria
uh you can't use them to define the word
object for the purposes of physics you
cannot use c
or touch primarily because you need a
second object to do see and touch
and that means you have a circular
definition you need an object to define
the word object
it's like you're using a synonym and
again if if you say well
i can't see your wife i can't touch your
wife yeah you can't see the guy on the
other side of the universe either and
does that mean he doesn't exist that
means he's not an object
the table he has is not an object so you
cannot use the c
touch criteria which is what everyone
uses out there
you can't see the air hopefully the air
blew your house down
hopefully it wasn't a ghost okay uh
mass
do all objects have mass no squares
don't have mass
neither do uh circles
uh superman you know the
has shape but uh he doesn't have mass
okay so all too deep figures don't have
mass
he said oh that's because you included
2d figures okay how about the 3d
table i'm thinking of does the word
table
refer to an object hopefully it does but
the one that's in
you know the one that's out here that i
can touch and see that one you can
sudden
see and touch and that one has mass how
about the one i'm thinking of
is that a table you know i can picture
it i can draw it for you i can tell you
which one i'm thinking of
and so i draw this thing that i'm
thinking of neither the one i drew
neither the one that i have in my head
has mass
or volume or motion
okay so you can't use any of these words
to define
the word object for the purposes of
physics the
only universal property shape
it's got to be a standalone object
meaning it doesn't depend on something
else it can't be a dependent object such
as
the halo of an angel
halo of an angel is either a plate or a
ring without the angel that's all we see
in front of us
we see objectively all that we see is a
ring or
a plate if you put the angel
you caught a halo why because it's a
dependent object you need the holy man
or the holy angel the guy with wings for
that to be called
a halo otherwise it's not a halo
otherwise it's just a plate a ring a
cloud whatever you want to call it
that is an object but a halo is not an
object halo is a concept
because you need the the object on which
it depends
same applies to the word field field is
not a standalone object
you need the magnet i can't bring a
field to the conference room
in fact uh every time you see the word
field you'll find some object related to
it there's this magnet
or or the electric uh terminal or
something
they'll put something in there you'll
never see the field all by itself
no one no one draws a field all by
itself because there is no physical
stand-alone object called the field
it's a dependent object meaning it's not
an object because if it's dependent it's
a concept you need two
objects to define the word concept
okay that's what a concept is a word
that
requires two objects that's what a field
is that's why you can't do
physics with a concept called field or
with a concept called
wave there's no such thing as a wave
okay and again you can go through the
list there
none of those qualifies as an object the
only one i'm going to mention again is
exist exist and the word object are not
synonyms
an error that both uh hume david hume
and um
emmanuel kant kent uh
made they they couldn't determine what
the difference was between the word
object then exists
and that's because they were thinking of
c and touch
and they say well you know whatever is
an object i
is what i can see and touch and whatever
exists i can see and touch so their
cinema i can't see any difference
well that's because they have the wrong
definition the definition is that which
has shape
some objects can be touched some can be
seen and not all objects exist
superman is an object that does not
exist a
circle is an object that does not exist
so you can't touch it you can't take it
home with you
because it's an object that does not
exist physics only deals with
objects that exist that eliminates all
two-dimensional objects
all two-dimensional figures where figure
is a synonym of the word object
okay um fellow says along the same lines
says uh if the klingon showed up and
launched the coffee table that
coffee table towards you would you
understand it's an object
uh that refers to the fact that i said
well you know here's the klingon on the
other side of the universe he's
gazillions of
light years away whatever right he's
very far away you can't see them you
can't touch them
he has a table is that table an object
the fact that you can't see or touch it
does that uh
you know deny the fact that that's a
that that thing is an object
of course is an object the word table is
an object anywhere in the universe
you don't have to see or touch it then
why is it an object it's an object
because it has shape not because you can
see or touch it
okay and so here's the answer um
in a second i got to get them from the
bottom here here's the answer
uh would you understand that a table is
an object even if the
klingon never showed up okay
does the klingon have to throw the table
at you for it to become an
object that's a question you got to
answer
i mean do you
prove uh that your table is an object by
throwing it at your wife or whatever
your boyfriend
okay is that what you do you say let me
show you that this is an object
i'm gonna hit you with it bang you over
the head with a table so that you know
it's an object
no hopefully you don't have to bang your
uh partner with uh with a table in order
for the table to be an object
it was an object before you grabbed it
with your hand okay why because it has
shape
that's the definition okay again another
fellow i think
here s says the following
along the same lines you have dismissed
the issue of defining shape
this is a critical mistake because you
know an object is that which has shape
so he says oh but you got to tell me
what shape is
that's the issue okay this is a critical
mistake
by your own standards even any model
critical term must be defined absolutely
not we don't define every word in the
dictionary
to please the extreme devil's advocate
you don't have to keep defining i say
okay what did you mean by the
what did you mean by uh which what did
you mean by that
i mean are those words any easier to
define than the word shape
can you define the word which can you
define the word fat
do we have to define every word for you
to understand what i just said
that which has shape has how about has
you know
it has like i have one penny in my
pocket
the same thing as saying oh i have a
headache
are those two same type of haves
is it easier to define the verb have
than it is to define the word shape
of course not and so what you're going
to just banter me forever and say well
why don't you define this word what
about this other word and just going to
go through the whole dictionary until i
define everywhere in the dictionary
that's not what we do in science in
science we have to compare the word
shape against what the list that i just
showed you
against c touch motion volume mass
we have to we we have 8 billion people
in this conference room the doors are
locked
we have to define the word object
because you can't do physics without an
object
and until we define the word object we
can't leave the room we have to select a
criterion
or if necessary criteria couple i don't
know
but the issue is we have to define the
word object before we leave the room
otherwise we can't do physics we can't
start doing physics
and so the issue is we have to compare
uh what cri
or or decide what criteria we're going
to use and for that we have to compare
all these
possibilities we have to compare shape
against
motion we have to compare c against
volume
we have to compare touch against exist
and so on down the line and out of all
those words we got to choose one
and the only one that qualifies is the
word shape that which has shape
now you say well i don't know what shape
is we'll go to a kindergarten and you
know uh
grab a ball and grab a cube
uh same volume same weight same color
and just show the kids and say what's
different about these
and they all say it's a shape
then you'll know what shape is you
probably missed a class in kindergarten
that's your whole problem okay
we don't define the word shape and
science we don't have to define the word
shape we need to know the difference
between
shape and see touch which is the
criteria
that are being used today in mathematics
because they think they're going to go
to the lab
see and touch and through see and touch
determine what is the mediator of light
what is the mediator of gravity what is
the mediator of magnetism
that's what they're doing they're using
uh by default
or casually they're using the word see
touch the the
notion of see and touch why because they
want to do an experiment
experiments are not part of science in
science we have to explain experiments
not do them
let someone else do the experiment we
just need to explain why
what what caused that to happen and for
that we need to
identify the invisible entities
objects things that mother nature uses
to do her stuff
every day okay uh so fella says shape
that which has a
boundary between what it is its body and
what it ain't
space or another object okay
keep that in mind he's saying that that
which has a boundary that's what he's
going to define
shape as he wants to give a definition
to the word shape
this excludes things like 1d lines 0d
points
infinite objects platonically ideal
fractals etc
from the definition readily includes 2d
and 3d
as edges and surfaces are boundaries
this is not only compatible with your
usage of the
term object but also enhances it
i think it takes away but ok let's find
out the boundary definition allows
contact between
objects this which is crucial for
the threads ability to twine into a rope
without
fusing into a rigid helix not to mention
any other
direction that requires touch okay let's
find out
here's the answer to this gentleman okay
and this is what the answer is he's a
dog chasing around his tail in circles
that's what he is
uh because he says an object that which
has shape he doesn't have a problem with
that he says we have to define the word
shape
okay what is shape he says shape is that
which has a boundary between what is
a body and what it ain't a space or
another object
uh so he's using the word body which is
the word object that's what a
word body means or he says another
object again he's using the word object
what is a boundary well boundary where
an object ends
uh in other words uh an object that he
needs the word object to define the word
boundary
so all this guy did was chase his tail
around but he's not smart enough to
figure it out
he's got object that would just shape
shape that which has boundary
boundary that which requires an object
or that where the object ends so we're
back to object
all he did was chase his tail around
so he he doesn't understand this uh you
know that
these people think of this simple that
they can just go in there and do
whatever they want and now they they
have uh problems with their logic
they're
they're irrational individuals they
don't understand that you can't
use synonyms or go around in circles
with definitions
you have to define all these words in
terms of
uh words that are not synonyms that
which has shape
shape is not an object shape is a
property
of an object an attribute of an object
shape itself is not a synonym of object
even though we sometimes informally say
you know shape like we treat it as an
object a synonym
but formally it's not shape is a
property it's like an
adjective it qualifies
uh what what an object is okay it's like
an adjective it's a
quality uh property an attribute
whatever you want to call it
okay um and here's uh just uh
like the icing on the cake because not
only this fellow was irrational here we
have mr euclid and all the greeks that
uh gave him this so-called knowledge
okay what did you
say let me put it over here and he ran
into trouble because he says
definition 13 this is in book one a
boundary is that which is an extremity
of anything
well good old euclid did not understand
that anything
means figure that's what any thing
means and so now he defines 14 he says
anything
in other words a figure is that which is
contained by any boundary or boundaries
all he did was revert back to 13 so he's
going back and forth
he's chasing his tail around he's saying
a boundary has something to do with
things
and what is a figure it has to do
something with boundaries
so all that euclid did was run around in
circles he did not understand this
and again people get stuck in these uh
chasing their tails around because they
don't pay attention to these little tiny
details
which have made a significant difference
these words are very
crucial to define if you're going to
start the the
discipline known as physics these people
never understood it they said
they thought that they could in their go
in there and just define these words
very
casually very informally and say uh okay
this this is good enough
no it ain't it ain't good enough you
need to be a lot more careful with your
definitions
okay definitions are crucial because
they form the foundations
of physics okay that's why they're
crucial you've got to define these words
properly
okay another person asks similar query
along the same line
out because i was covering the mandelson
brought
shapes the other day okay which is that
one there on the bottom
left that's a mon mando brought set
okay it's called so the mandelbrot
mandelbrot set
is a shape because it doesn't move
correct so far so good
we do a fractal zoom and now they aren't
shapes because of motion
correct the word shape is a static
concept
okay like standing is a static concept
moving
is a dynamic concept but standing is a
static
concept okay you're not doing any motion
it's a relation with respect to
something else so we're saying that the
tree is standing or the
rock is standing it's not doing anything
so standing is a
is a static concept like direction is a
static concept you're not moving
anything
you can move along a direction but the
word direction itself
requires two objects first and second
it's a static
concept there's nothing moving that you
need
to have moved within the word direction
all you have is just a like an
orientation a pointing
a facing between two objects that's all
you have when with the word direction
and so what's the issue here the issue
is that yeah um a mandelbrot set
if it's a static thing like you see on
the left
that is a shape nothing's moving it's a
static concept so far so far we're okay
now look at the one on the right
well i don't know is that a shape oh it
just moved sorry i can't tell you
because it keeps moving
so that's not a shape that's not an
object that i'm staring i'm staring at a
movie
but what's the issue the issue is i can
take a cross
section of that in other words one frame
freeze that that one has shape hopefully
each frame of the film in that movie
has shape i have to make it stand still
now it is a shape
it has shape whatever is in that frame
but
i can't say that something that is
moving like this constantly
that's a movie that's a movie with
gazillions of shapes
that's not a shape that's a movie of
many shapes
that's and again that's not a shape that
does not qualify as shape
shape is a static concept okay
uh so yeah because they're uh in motion
they're not aesthetic
they're not shapes they're not a static
concept i paused the video
did it magically become a shape uh not
the video
but one of the frames of the video has
shapes
in it in other words the objects in
there all have shapes
okay very simple is it now an object
because it has shape
no the object has shape that's inside
the frame
of the movie you stop the movie but
you're not looking at the whole movie
you're looking at just
one frame in the movie whatever's in
that frame had better have shape
otherwise you're staring at a blank uh
frame
that's it did one jump off the screen
and hit you in the head that hard no you
don't have to have
uh objects hit you we don't rely on
touch
to define the the word or see for that
matter to define what an object is
no uh an object is that which has shape
all on its own before
it hits you okay the baseball bat is an
object before
it hits you okay hopefully i don't have
to use it
[Laughter]
okay so yeah shape is a static concept
okay let's go with the next question or
comment
paul says absolutely no one has and no
one
ever will possessed a two dimensional
object there is nothing
as such go outside today and wonder
about your shadow
because a shadow is not an object and a
shadow
does not have shape not in physics in
ordinary speech
shadows people say oh yeah the shape of
the shadow
not infinity you can't say that in you
cannot say that in physics okay
not in physics why let me tell you why
you can't say that in physics
it is irrational to say that to say that
a shadow
has shape shadow have shape
uh tongue twister there okay okay here
it is
first of all guy says no thing that's
what nothing means
no thing and yeah we do have a thing
thing is that which has shape
so if the two-dimensional object
hopefully has shape that part
we have you don't have to possess it
because uh
an object is not that which you possess
meaning that you can touch
that's not the definition of the word
object an object is that which has shape
not that which you can possess you don't
possess
the the table that the klingon has
two gazillions of miles away okay
you don't possess that table so touching
seeing possessing none of those
are definitions of the word thing a
thing
is that which has shape a circle is an
object for the purposes of science why
because it has shape
we have no purpose for inexistent 2d
objects such as circles and physics
physics deals only with 3d
objects now shadow why is a shadow not
an object because the word
shadow means blocked light there is no
physical standalone
object called block light okay now if
you see that there is a physical object
called black light please bring it to
the conference and we'll find out if a
shadow this black light
has shape okay black light is not a
shape
because it's got to be a standalone
object okay and then shadow
is not a standalone anything shadow is a
concept and concepts do not
have shape okay no standalone objects
such as blocked light
okay i hope that's clear to a rational
human being
it is not to religious people who see
their
religion suddenly die because the word
object destroys
all religions okay
father says here it is says
have you tried to tell a surfer have you
tried to tell a surfer that a wave isn't
a physical
object it's just a verb right
no one no waves today johnny they are
verbs
okay uh so what's the problem here let's
see if a rational
person can figure this out okay and here
it is
well it says uh i mean here it is the
answer says exactly what a surfer is
surfing on is known as water in physics
not waves
no such thing as waves and there you see
uh
is that a wave no that's a flag not a
wave
wave is what the flag is doing the
object is is flagged
you hopefully you won't confuse the noun
flag with the
verb wave and that's the same thing on
the left
on the left what you have is a surfer
and he's on water
not on a wave okay the fact that we
informally
say call it a wave whatever the water is
doing
that should not be confused with a noun
but that's what people do they
bring all these words of ordinary speech
these notions
they bring them into physics and they
say oh the wave you can't do that in
physics you got to bring the object not
the not what it's doing and calling it a
noun
that's where the problem is and there
you have the uh
the famous saying the definition of the
word object
destroys all religions
okay
so here's the punchline on that let's
see if
people can understand what i'm saying
here okay
is the god you pray to an object
or a concept okay does your god have
shape or not
i mean i don't care if you believe in
the god of the christian bible
or for that matter the koran or whatever
i don't care if you believe in space
time is that what you pray to you pray
to the black hole to the
planetary atom to energy you know that
mystical stuff that floats everywhere
nobody knows what it is
to the wave i don't care what your god
is
you gotta tell me if your god is an
object
or a concept and i brought that issue up
with
some um uh folks uh planetarians
palestinians who were in uh uh
aberdeen uh scotland a few years back i
think
2010. i went to scotland to a conference
and these
and i asked them we went to lunch with
them
nice fellas and so they were uh
muslims and so i asked them i said okay
is your god an object or a concept
does your god have shape or doesn't he
and that stumped them because i got
different answers one guy said
well if i knew what god is then uh i
wouldn't he wouldn't be so great
that's the type of answer one guy gave
me another guy said well you know i mean
he's both oh he's both he's he has shape
and doesn't have shape
simultaneously and he said well he can
be one or the other he can turn from
shape to no shape no no that's not the
question the question is at any point in
time
does he have shape or not shape and yeah
that's where they start
thinking they never ask that question to
themselves
and they have no answer for that because
it's a black or white issue it's either
black or white
it's on or off it's yes or no you can't
say
oh it has shape but it doesn't or you
know i don't know
and i'll find out you can't answer like
that it's just a
straightforward question does your god
have shape or not who do you pray
to do you pray to the to space time does
space time have shape or not
that's the issue and that's why the word
object destroys all religion it compels
the believer in this nonsense
to tell me to tell you right
uh whether their god the one they pray
to the one they believe in
has shape or not and of course they're
going to wheeze a lot of that one
they're going to do everything in their
power for you not to destroy their
religion
because that sentence there destroys
their religion that comment
the definition of the word object the
scientific definition of the word object
destroys
all religions whoever you god you
believe in
you got to tell me whether he's an
object or a constant and if you believe
that your concept was an object
which is typically the case and you
treat them like an object when it's
really an
abstract concept you know black hole for
example
then you got a serious problem because
now you realize
what physics is all about what is
physics about objects
first and foremost you need an object
you can't
bring in a concept love and treat it
like an object say oh i'm going to move
the heart around
now if you're going to move the heart
decide whether you're going to be moving
the heart or the love
if you're going to move love around you
got a problem because love is a concept
you can't move
love if you're going to move a heart
don't call it love
period we're done okay okay uh
one file says
says uh scientists
they call them scientists they're not
scientists they're just a bunch of
nobodies
that have a phd and they call themselves
scientists because everybody believes
that a scientist someone who has a phd
even though the guy did was warm a seed
in college during 10 years
they're called scientists or physicists
or mathematical physicists or whatever
no they're not scientists a scientist a
guy who thinks who rationalizes who
can explain that's a scientist but a guy
who who does
nonsense at the lab and cannot explain
anything that's not a scientist
scientists at the london university
faculty of engineering in sweden have
managed to capture the electron motion
for the first time
and this is the nonsense that these
so-called scientists come up with they
show you that they say oh look
i'm a scientist i filmed the electron
well i don't care if you filmed it or
you described it mathematically that's
not a scientist a scientist is a guy who
explained
so what is it that a scientist has to
explain well how about if they explain
this now we have the movie
great okay now explain this explain
if you can what an atom looks like
i mean if your blue ball looks like that
blue ball going around right because
that's what they claim
that they filmed okay so we got that
blue ball going around what we need for
you to tell us
is what your atom looks like according
to niels bohr the atoms use
that still used today is that that
electron jumps between
energy levels okay around
a nucleus or proton in the case of the
hydrogen atom
great i need to know what the white
stuff is within the two circles
what is the white stuff that compels the
electron bead not to remain faithful to
the proton and not fly away
spontaneously
that's what you need to answer if you
cannot answer that question
you're kicked out of the conference room
you're not allowed to give your
presentation your dissertation
because you don't have an atom so
you've got to start by justifying your
atom right now they can't justify their
atom
so i don't care if they film the
electron they cannot put that
electron in an atom and show us the atom
that's the problem
so it shows you that doing experiments
and filming this nonsense that these
people film there
give us no idea whatsoever of
what science is about science is about
explaining something
and right now what they cannot explain
with that little electron that they film
supposedly film uh is that uh they
cannot tell us what their atom looks
like we need to know what their atom
looks like and that's a conceptual issue
has nothing to do with running
experiments in the lab now and there's
another problem you can see that
electron beat on the lower left
the blue one there that these people so
the scientists so-called scientists
filmed it has shape it has some diameter
has some size
and to this day the official version
from quantum mechanics
is that the electron is a point particle
it has no
shape it has no size it has no radius
how can these people film what official
dumb
says has no shape no size no diameter no
radius no nothing no volume
so what did they film what is this
nonsense
so they take a picture or a film of
something they bring and say oh we
filmed the electorate and give us our
noble
absolute nonsense it shows you know how
ridiculous so-called science
mathematical physics has become that's
what it shows that's what that's
evidence of okay um
question around along the thread the
rope
model here we have them bill gate he
cannot use the word shape without
evoking geometry
i don't know why because math has
nothing to do with shape geometry
what he calls geometry is uh
numbers relations equations measurement
that's got nothing to do with physics
which has to do with
shape so yeah we don't need geometry not
the geometry that the mathematicians do
which are object-less there are no
objects in so-called
geometry so uh yeah it's the other way
around
we can use the word shape because we're
going to do physics geometry the
mathematicians
they cannot use the word shape because
they have no use for the word shape or
for objects
they don't deal with objects they deal
with itineraries measurement
you know what is an itinerary what
they're doing is unrolling the measuring
tape
that's what it is so they measure and
they say oh we measure what did you
measure
you measured how a location went from
location a to location b
that's what they did they just measured
locations and the motion of locations
or a series of locations and what
they're conceptually doing is unrolling
the measuring tape that's all it is
so they're looking at the starting point
of the tape and the ending point of the
tape
they measure that they say one meter and
that's what they use they use the one
meter they have no use
for the actual physical object that
measures one meter
okay so hopefully that's clear math is
the language he says
it true even rational science is in
absolutely not we have no use for math
whatsoever
and if he doesn't use it he can't
explain anything at all
math is a language that does not explain
and cannot
explain mathematics can only describe
has no power no authority
okay granted to it to explain anything
you cannot explain anything with math
you can only describe
and if you haven't learned that you know
nothing about math
okay an equation is a description
explains absolutely nothing
explain you have to use a different type
of language you can use chinese you can
use greek
you know i know it's greek to you but
you can use those languages
but you cannot use math to explain
math can only describe if you haven't
learned that again you haven't you don't
know
nothing about math bill gates thread is
an infinite object
where did he get that oh my god what are
these people having their minds or
reminder
therefore we can't use your definition
of object in rational science and any
definition of
object will have to allow for the use of
the of 1d lines and 0d points
because of how many dimensions the
thread has
the thread has three dimensions what
part don't you understand it's 3d it has
length width and height
yes every object can be represented as
an itinerary
in the thread no we don't represent a
dog
with an itinerary you got to put the dog
sorry
there is no no substitute that you can
put especially in motion
you can't put a verb to represent a dog
you got to put the dog
okay but here's the issue uh he says my
he talks about my thread here's the
thread
okay here you have two threads each one
forms a different universe
those threads turn into every atom in
each
uh universe and you can see that the
thread
first has shape and then one thread has
distance with respect to another that
means that
they both exist because they meet the
condition of the word exist
they have distance in other words
location with respect to each other
we have the word exist so we have the
thread and we have existence
we have no we have the thread is an
object and we have the
object that exists we have no problem
here because we we can
define the word object it has shape and
we can define the word
exist because one has location with
respect to the other
period we're done okay that's how simple
it was
let's move on to the next question
because we're going to return to that
one
and here fella says
so it's not infinite by the way each one
of those is a closed loop thread so it's
not
infinite infinite is you going around
the thread that's not infinite it's
called incessant
running not in do not confuse the word
incessant which is what the
idiots of math do with the word infinite
infinite is an
adjective can only be applied to objects
there is no such thing as an infinite
object because it's an oxymoron
self-contradiction all objects are
finite
therefore the word infinite is an
irrational term
to introduce into physics into science
you can use it in ordinary speech
not in physics not in science and
the thread is not an infinite object
it's it's an it's a
closed loop finite object that does not
stretch
which is the next issue here but you can
run around it forever
if that's what you call infinite you
don't know what the word infinite means
it's incessant running
incessant running is not infinite okay
and this vowel says
says uh how stretching or bending happen
in single piece thread
oh my god uh the thread doesn't stretch
it doesn't stretch it's made of a single
piece it doesn't stretch okay
so there's a there's only so much matter
in the universe
and that's the amount of thread you
could say
the closed loop thread has only a
certain length if
we could stretch it completely out undo
all the atoms and just stretch out all
we would have is a single thread
in the universe that makes up all matter
it doesn't stretch it's made of a single
piece
we're done matter does not create itself
because
there's only so much matter in our
universe unless there's another parallel
universe
another parallel thread in which uh
case uh we have two universes a parallel
universe
none of the atoms of that universe are
connected to
any of the atoms of our universe we
cannot see that universe
we cannot touch it touch it probably but
we cannot see it
why we cannot see it because in order to
see you have to have the
rope come into your eye and none
of the ropes of that universe are
connected to the ropes
of uh to the atoms of your eye or to our
universe
okay now we can still collide we can't
see
but we can collide because atoms can
still collide surface against surface
if they happen the two universes happen
to cross through each other
and that's the only time you can see uh
you can experience
uh an atom coming through your wall and
you know maybe hitting you or whatever
or out there in the in the field
uh again that's a speculation i don't
think two universes can collide they're
probably not even close together if
there is another universe
parallel universe out there okay so
what is our uh universe like uh what is
the thread like okay well here let me
let me show you okay see if i can show
you this
give me a second here uh
it says how can you bend it how does a
thread bend
i'm gonna do an experiment for you okay
very important experiment
you like experiments i'll do an
experiment in front of you and this is
very uh expensive very uh
unusual experiment okay i'm gonna bend
the thread for you i'm gonna show you
how it bends okay here's the thread
okay watch it carefully and there i i
bent the
thread okay see how
how hard that was that's how it blends
that's
now you know how thread bends that's a
thread and air bending
and i did it several times i hope you
caught that
okay you can watch the movie later on
you'll find out that i did actually bend
the thread
so that's how it bends i mean i don't
know what question you want answered
that's how you bend the thread we're
done okay that's how a thread
bends
okay let's move on to a more rational
question
here a person asks
i think it's more irrational we'll find
out uh the rope is under tension
everywhere yeah
and the rope is fluid yeah okay what
gate
getty has a surreal self-contradictory
object that fails his own criterion of
existence uh-huh to have
location with respect to another object
well again i showed you
uh here okay there you have it
uh so there is no contradiction there
you have two threads one has distance
location with respect to the other so
both of those threads exist so we're
done i guess
that's it there's no more than that okay
uh
so we do have existence we have an
object in existence both because we have
location that's the definition of
existence object with location
any irrational thinker can come to the
conclusion that all fundamental
non-composite objects are fully solid
and do not deform in any way
in our everyday world in fact we don't
have such an object in
our everyday world even a steel beam is
made out of
atoms and it has space in between
you know the atoms that's what gives
shape
or provide shape or contrast to each
atom so there is no such thing
as something made of a single piece in
our everyday world
now uh you have steel beam which we say
well it's quite rigid yeah
it is quite rigid but the quick issue
here is you cannot extrapolate
to mother nature's uh world
all the properties that we have in our
everyday macro world
not all of them not all the properties
or attributes
are transferable to mother nature's
world
obviously mother nature runs a different
kind of world than we do
in our everyday world uh the sea and
touch world
because her mediators are invisible
and intangible so you gotta explain
invisibility and intangibility
you gotta make an assumption about what
she could be using there because
otherwise you're replacing that with
spirits so she
is using some kind of object that we
cannot see or touch
and none of that can be imitated by
anything we have in our everyday world
you cannot go to the lab
and imitate uh her world her invisible
intangible world whatever you do is
going to be seeable and touchable if
you're going to the lab
experiment can only do deal with seeable
and touchable with
visibility and touchability tangibility
experiments do not deal with the
invisible
to to elucidate the mediator
you will not be able to deal with c and
touch because mother nature doesn't use
c and touch rc and touch to run her
world so you got to make some new
assumptions and among them is that that
um you know this notion that
if it's made out of a single piece it's
rigid
no mother nature's world is in reverse
it's made out of single piece and it is
not
rigid it is a malleable single
piece entity that she uses just like
it's invisible
just like it's intangible okay why is it
intangible
okay because seeable is a little easier
to explain probably
i put this up let me put it one more
time we have the sliding hand okay let's
make sure we understand the concept
why it's uh untouchable
why it's intangible here it is you have
five fingers and we're pulling one atom
just at random from each finger the the
hand is moving towards the ball okay
what the what the atoms are doing is
sliding through the ropes
why because the rope is made out of two
strands
and the atom is somewhere in in the
middle here let me put it here
okay and so the rope itself each one of
these threads
make up the atom imagine you have the
abacus in front of you okay and you have
these beads that you can
slide that's more or less what i'm
showing there
so so you have these beads they slide
but it turns out that the beads are made
of the same
wire that it's sliding through
so the wire one wire goes above the
other one goes through the center
and the bead is just sliding through
this wire that makes up the bead
the bead does not really touch the wire
because it is
made of the wire you can say it touches
it at all times
the bead can touch another bead can bang
against another bead
but it cannot bang against the wire of
which
it is made and through which it's
sliding that's what i'm showing here you
see the atoms are sliding through the
ropes those are ropes okay
and the ropes make up the atom so you
can't touch the rope itself you can only
touch another atom you can't touch the
rope of which the atom is made
that's why you cannot touch these atoms
okay and i don't know if that sank
what we're talking about is atoms
sliding through the ropes
okay and there was another issue erased
here let me put that back in here okay
it says the rope
is under okay any rational thinker okay
got that
i investigated ideas where the rope is
made of inconceivably
tiny but absolutely rigid chain links
uh-huh he thinks he's going to do this
with a chain he's going to talk about
you know links being the chain so he's
going to say that
the so-called rope he's going to put a
chain in there he's going to
put links one right after another in
series okay so
again the notion of a chain a chain of
fundamental objects is permanently
intact by definition but
is allowed to deform simply by
reorientation
of the rigid links just as in real macro
scale metal chain
what this guy is proposing is quantum
mechanics particles
he's proposing that the particles look
like
links okay and so he wants to fix one
problem but he
opens up a can of worms in another sense
and he doesn't realize that because he
doesn't have the mental capacity
to understand what he's doing okay what
he's doing he's saying i'm gonna replace
the rope because i don't like the rope
because the rope is made out of single
piece
and then we can't go through it we can't
we have this problem of uh
ropes crossing etc threads hitting each
other and so on so he said no i'm going
to replace the rope and i'm just going
to put a bunch of links and make a chain
well now he created a bigger monster
he's got more questions to answer
than the rope and here are the questions
he's got to answer
so let's put this up there so we can
have something graphic
okay um here's the chain
okay so here we have a chain okay and
what this guy is saying that
we have all these links we'll call them
links okay
chain links and so if we can
move the chain now because now he says
see now we can see why it's malleable
great
okay we fixed the malleability problem
so we he
he alluded these the
thread made of a single piece which is
malleable that's the one he's going to
address here
so he says here if we put links there we
solve the problem malleability
okay now that chain breaks okay because
it's got a break
because we're going to have chain going
through chain
okay that's the first issue and here the
problem is that if it breaks
how does that link uh go back and become
part of a chain again how does
these how do these invisible or or loose
links
uh combine again to make a chain
and then we have the problem is what
does your proton look like
which is a bigger problem i mean with
the threads no problem we have a thread
going to do the center of the atom we
have the star in the center of the atom
which is you know pointing in different
directions i think i have a picture here
okay let me show you this so you see
what i'm talking about
okay here it is okay
so you can see the atom is made out of
those
i've got it moving fast but you know you
can see what i'm talking about here
the proton is made of threads one thread
goes around forms the
electron shell or membrane that
encapsulates the star in the center the
center is made of all the threads
we call them electric threads
arbitrarily to keep with convention
and those threads come from every atom
in the universe so we have an
explanation for the proton
how do you explain this with these
chains that he put up here you know let
me put that back up here
how do you explain it with that how do
you explain the proton with these chains
what is the this ridiculous notion of
chains
making up the proton that's what he's
got to explain
okay and so yeah you can't elude that
uh question and i think i have one more
issue there
let me see if i get it here at the
bottom
uh yeah what he's proposing essentially
is what uh string theory proposes
and it looks more or less like this that
exactly but he's saying look
and those rings are malleable in string
theory uh
think of them as solids as uh as
undeformable you know you can't deform
these like you see them here
uh they're made of a single piece okay
and they're links
and he so you have all these little
links going around how do they combine
and form these chains
that's what he's gonna answer and so uh
this is the ball is in his court he's
got more to answer than uh
what we find with a rope model and with
that i'll see you
next time on what is it on sunday
uh you don't even know what date of
23 i think it is we'll see you then
sunday
next week by uh end of the week bye bye
and have a good weekend